became the greatest military aviator in
history
after graduation is an airplane mechanic
in the
united states army air forces
three months later japan attacked pearl
harbor
the axis powers declared war
war had come to america
and after a few months as a mechanic
checker applied to be a pilot
and that changed history he later said
he made that faithful decision because
he was
sick of getting kitchen duty
he also said i quote i noticed the
pilots didn't have dirty hands
they all had beautiful girls
on his first flight private jager
history records was nervous
but it was long before he distinguished
himself as the best pilot in his class
a year later he deployed to europe at
just 20
years of age he flew eight combat
missions and shot down two nazi fighters
on his eighth mission he was shot down
over france
moving into the leg and his head he was
smuggled over the mountains into spain
with a
[Music]
and when his request was denied he
appealed to the supreme allied commander
[Music]
but in the case yeager eisenhower made
an exception
on 12 october 1944 leading three fighter
squadrons
escalating bombers over germany he shot
down five
enemy planes making him
[Music]
that was all accomplished
but he was just 22 years of age
while he was training in california
he went to a local gym to help organize
the us
dance and that's where he met
what he would want to say was as pretty
as a movie star
he succeeded organizing the dance on
their first date
together they raised four amazing
children including two sons
who served in the uniform of the united
states as well
after the war with glenn set his side he
was sent to the desert
edwards air force base which is one of
america's first test pilots
in october of 1947
wearing a football helmet that he bought
with his own
[Music]
and became the first human being ever to
break the sound
and it's just 24 years of age
chuck yeager became an inspiration to an
entire generation of american highers
[Music]
his daring maneuvers his unshakable
[Music]
confidence
this wolf wrote in that timeless book
and i quote
anybody who travels on airlines in the
united states gets to the voice of
airline pilot over the intercom
download columns they also hear that
pilots from massachusetts oregon
began talking with the west virginia
accent
his influence was destroyed
and when warrior came to america again
[Music]
chuck giggs stepped forward
he became one of the first americans
after one was seized
and when the vietnam war came he flew
another 127
combat missions in the service of the
united states
all told over more than 30 years of
service
chuck gaber flew more than 350
military planes a total of more than 10
000.
and breakthroughs that he achieved made
our space program possible
in fact general yeager led the air force
aerospace research pilot school
where he trained almost half of the
airmen who would one day become
astronauts and
space programs that took us to the moon
in fact we were joined by another heroic
american airman who was actually hired
by general
yeager to serve
different apollo missions including
serving as the immortal voice
responding to the artist he's a patriot
witness of faith and the youngest man
ever you all join me and thank
general charlie duke for his lifetime
but for all his accomplishments his
greatest accomplishment for sure
a decade after the yeager family lost
chuckles for a second
one day he
victoria
[Music]
it's a great honor for me to be here
today as vice president of the united
states
me say it's also a personal privilege
that i will cherish for the rest
you see my wife's father was an officer
in the air force
he inspired karen to get her pilot's
license when she was just in the 20s
our son is a marine corps fighter
her son-in-law is currently deployed
and then my son-in-law's late father was
an aviation enthusiast
and what generations of our family have
in common
is that we've all been inspired by the
life
service
but the truth is chuck kinder has been
an inspiration to every american
and it will be throughout time
in fact the crew of the cockpit of air
force ii
told me this morning before we took off
from henry's air force
virginia
when our son was a little boy and his
air force grandfather had frank
and it now has in his home not far from
the base of the station
it's entitled
and as america bids farewell to our
nation's greatest state
the words
[Music]
and i believe they are reflective
[Music]
as we think about that day in general
about the last pair
oh
[Music]
you've done a hundred things you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's face it
[Music]
do you
he was his commander
the bible tells us to mourn with those
who are born
america will
to produce those who follow this
deep in the heart
[Music]
and as long as american pilots
[Music]
and the gods
[Applause]